hey everybody welcome back to building a
wooden coaster for Zuri Gardens now I
know you've probably looked at the
length of this video and you're very
much afraid of what's gonna happen here
why this is more than half an hour long
and first of all I have to say I already
cut out a lot of footage from this just
to make this video shorter I said I
would make this a two-part video so it's
two parts but really I could have filled
a bunch of episodes with the amount of
footage that I had so I had to cut out
some of the most boring parts but at the
same time I okay maybe I'm just so evil
but at the same time I want to keep most
of the footage here and show most of the
support work which ends up being a very
time-consuming activity as you might
think
that said there is light at the end of
the tunnel I will give some cinematic
shots of the coaster and a POV at the
end of this video so you can either stay
here for the full half an hour that I'm
gonna try and coincide through this or
you know just skip forward to the
cinematic parts if you're interested in
that should be somewhere around just
after the 30 minute mark but for the
rest of us who are staying behind here I
have to admit this is at and this is as
much a very difficult journey for you as
it is for me I know this is a very long
video and I literally didn't know what I
would even do with this video because
normally I have a lot of things to talk
about or at least I can come up with
things to talk about in my videos what I
tend to do is I just watch back
generally what the time-lapse is about
get a notepad file and get some things
that I want to talk about and just kind
of go from there and see wherever my
stream of consciousness takes me but in
this case this really is 30 minutes just
building wooden supports mostly so
nothing really changes and there's not a
lot that I can say directly rating to
what's gonna be happening on the screen
so I've got a good list of topics that I
want to talk about with you
and we'll see how I make my way through
that list for now though just as a very
quick introduction as to what I'm
actually doing in this episode so you
just told me finish off the last part of
the layouts it was a pretty simple part
just some curves very low to the ground
to finish it up because there's not a
lot of speed left but I still wanted to
maintain that feeling that you get on so
many GCI coasters where it really feels
like the coaster doesn't slow down all
the way until you're in the brake run
which is really cool though
thank you I'm keeping some of the last
parts of the layout very close to the
ground just to make sure that I'm making
the most of my speed and at this point I
started work on what is probably the
most important and most annoying thing
out of this whole project which is
supporting this this turn around
elements here which is also kind of my
favorites at the same time I really have
very mixed feelings about this because
at once it was definitely the most
difficult part of the support work to
get done but on the other hand I think
it's also one of the the best parts what
I managed to get done here and probably
also one of the most iconic ones
Johnse said that he wanted a big mess of
wooden supports like you would see on
many GCI coasters in real life with
those diagonal beams slanting out from
the track and with all of the beams in
between as well that are so dense that
you sometimes can't even see through the
supports and that is mostly what's gonna
be happening on this section of the
track for the most part also because
this is the only part of the track where
the the coaster is quite high off the
ground for a long amount of time because
for most of the rest of the layouts it's
all very close to the ground which like
I said is partly because I want to
maintain a sensation of speed throughout
the entire layout but I'd be lying if I
didn't say that I was also kind of happy
to try to avoid having too much support
working but yeah this this turn here is
gonna be quite iconic
I suppose because it has those very
typical GCI supports on the sides with
all the diagonal beams which is going to
take quite some time to do because like
I kind of explained in the last episode
we have the beams which are parallel to
the track or well really 90 degrees from
the track going from the catwalk to the
ground and then in between that are the
horizontal beams and in between that I
put the the sort of diagonal
cross-hatching beams there and finally
connecting the horizontal beams and the
diagonal beams are also going to be
vertical beams going back to the ground
and then all of those beams are gonna
need footers when they reach the ground
and I do have to say before anyone
mentions this that this is one of the
things where this coaster is kind of
unrealistic there are a few things that
I should mention that are a bit off
about this coaster and one of them is
that the footers are square and in real
life GC eyes have circular footers and
there are actually good pieces for this
I remember finding one of the pillar
pieces in the scenery tab is actually
quite goodness but the problem was that
I started off with the square ones just
imitating the in-game ones and a half
way through the process of adding
footers to the coaster I also don't want
to remove all of the old footers or put
new round ones over them so I'm just
gonna keep them like they are not to
mention that if I were to replace them
with circular ones I not just have to
replace them on the custom supports that
I built but really realistically also on
the in-game supports which would be a
monumental task that's not to say that
this whole project in general isn't a
monumental task but at the end at some
point I need to give this file back to
my to mask bandit and geek ISM as well
because you know they're gonna want to
work on this at last and I've been
stalling on their projects for long
enough I think so that is one of the
less realistic things about this coaster
another one that I'd want to give a
quick shout is somebody commented on the
last video that apparently many GCI
coasters have one section of their
supports where they just put decorative
wooden planks and he gave one example to
be honest I've never seen this before
but it actually looked kind of cool but
I didn't end up doing it because I sort
of forgot about it and then when I was
almost at the end of this I decided to
not record my supporting anymore anyway
because I already had way too much
footage and I just wanted to round off
everything so I didn't end up doing that
so that was just a small finishing touch
that I have to say I'm sorry for not
deciding to add that I hope you
understand that I was very done with all
of these wooden pieces by the time I got
done with supporting this
do I sound salty at all again I do have
to say that I'm really happy with the
result but the process of this is
definitely quite draining and here I
also have to say that I'm really glad
that this was just that this was a
collab actually and that mask bandit and
geek ism asked me to do this because
doing it for somebody else is a good
motivation or push to actually go forth
and finish the support work because if
this was my own thing I would have
probably supported one curve and then
realized that I would not enjoy doing
the rest so having that extra motivation
to actually do it because it's a collab
it was really nice so I'd like to thank
you guys for that as well and this one's
for masked bandit and geek ISM of course
oh god how how far am i over almost at
10 minutes that's not too bad I still
have a bunch of stuff that I need to
talk about so for one the coaster
actually has a name now I didn't talk
about that in the last video just
because there wasn't a name but we've
settled on the name silverback which
should fit the African theme of the park
quite well most of the areas and
buildings etc in the park have Swahili
words so far and we did come up with
this where he leaned aim for this
coaster which was something for typhoon
I forgot the exact name but silverback
just fit the coaster really well
fits the zoo theme of the park and
something which I didn't realize until
master knit and geek isn't pointed it
out to me is that of course silverback
is kind of similar to silver ants so
it's a small reference to my name as
well so yeah I think it's a fitting name
for the coaster I guess it's also one
that's easy to pronounce because as much
as this one Healey name ideas were
really cool in a sense I guess you do
need some kind of international market
stability when it comes to a flagship
attraction right like this so I can kind
of see why they didn't go the the way of
the efteling and make their main coaster
super unpronounceable so yeah that's
that now I also want to talk about this
coaster that I made about two years ago
that I quickly named drops in the last
episode I think called gambits this was
my first try at making a GCI coaster in
planet coaster and it was also my last
one until this one I think gambit was
actually better than this coaster but
about all of the time that I spent in to
making supports for this coaster I spent
on making just the layouts for gambit
alone let alone supports so even though
I think the end result was slightly
better than this the amount of time that
I had to put into it was significant
much more so I think in the end I made a
good decision to try and keep this
coaster you know somewhat restricted in
terms of how far I would go with
experimenting with the track I made
gambits using the four meter method
which meant that especially for a TCI
coaster like this I had to pay very
close attention to which parts of the
track I would smooth out and which I
didn't because normally when you use the
four meter method you just kind of
smooth out everything and eventually the
trunk becomes smooth enough but in the
case of gambit I also wanted to preserve
the typical snappy transitions of GCI
coasters and the quick pops of airtime
that you have everywhere so the
smoothing had to be pretty precise
everywhere so that made the already
time-consuming four meter method
even more time-consuming and then
there's just the fact that it's the four
meter method as well which is quite
annoying and the the very idea of gambit
as a terrain conforming GCI coaster was
born from the fact that I wanted to
build a GCI coaster in planet coaster
but it was really hard to do it on the
flatland because at the time we didn't
have the friction sliders yet and for
some reason the GCI coaster in the game
had way too much friction on it so
gambit is built into the hill just to
maintain a good speed throughout the
entire layout while at the same time
still having that very high friction
that the game gives you so really it's
not even a very realistic layouts
realistically in real life it would be
way too fast I just kind of made it to
overcome the limitations of planet
coaster at the time and the problem was
that very shortly after I finished the
layout for gambits and uploaded the
video a friction slider was added to
Planet coaster which is not a problem
per se I'm actually really happy that
this was added and it basically allows
us to make realistic coasters nowadays
or realistic wooden coasters because
most of the friction settings were
pretty much good so really without the
friction slider I wouldn't be building
this wooden coaster right here right now
so definitely don't want to throw any
shade on that one but I was feeling a
little bit be motivated about gambits
because I went out of my way to overcome
a limitation that was quickly is solved
thereafter so that was a bit awkward but
I do have to say gambits might and I
need to say might with a capital M here
and actually no capital all letters just
make them all caps and bold maybe gambit
is gonna return someday a very slight
possibility because I gave the the file
over to Joshua who I've known for a
while mostly due to his fury three to
five recreation which is probably the
best recreation of any coaster that I
have ever seen in planet coaster and
it's not even completely finished it's
insanely accurate and well I know that
he isn't quite that well-known
especially if you're just on YouTube and
not in some of the deeper reaches of the
planet coaster community on some discs
or it's like the bro nation discord for
instance but the his fury three-to-five
recreation is absolutely amazing and he
just goes above and beyond to try and
make things realistic so he just sent me
a message on this cord asking if he
could have the file and given his track
record no pun intended I figured I could
just hand it over to him and see if he
was able to do anything with it so he's
currently working on some of the
supports I believe and reworking some of
the parts of the layouts as well so
together with him and also the work that
free the bear did earlier on the
supports maybe
gambit is gonna return one day albeit
with a lot of help from other people so
I I should really not give myself any
credit for this it just seems like
there's been a lot of renewed interest
in GCI coasters in planet coaster since
I released the last video which is
absolutely amazing to see I saw so many
pictures of people currently making GCI
coasters or going back to some of the
DCI coasters that they tried building
earlier and it is always really
interesting to see because this is one
of those things that's really you know
limited to the the most crazy insane
coaster enthusiasts because most people
you know wouldn't care too much about
any particular company of wooden coaster
per se a wooden coaster is more or less
a wooden coaster to the layman but in in
case in the in the case of DCI and
coaster enthusiasts it's just such a
tiny niche interest that so many people
are just so invested in and try their
best to try and make something as close
as possible to whatever this specific
company puts out it's just really
interesting and for somebody who's as
into the nerdy side of coasters as I
it's just really cool to see so yeah
that's been awesome
I'm really happy actually in general
with all of the support that the first
video had been given so honestly thank
you guys for that I really didn't expect
it to you know be this well-received I
thought people would just get kind of
bored by me placing wooden posts for an
extended amount of time but the
reception on that video was way better
than anything I ever expected so thank
you guys for that that's amazing
do I have anything else that I want to
talk about we've about hit the halfway
mark and a lot of supports have been
done already I'm getting now to this
point which I'm not sure you know if it
was a good idea to actually add custom
supports here because maybe mass
mandates and geek ISM are going to mess
with this area a bit but it's going to
be tricky because the track that we have
running up here just above the station
is going to be the station flyby or it's
just gonna fly just past the station
building but in any case it's that
typical GCI element we're halfway
through the layouts you just fly by the
station in a straight piece of track it
gives you a bit of a breather as well
for just one second before you go back
into the madness but I did decide to
kind of custom support this for a bit
but the supports don't actually make
that much sense I have to admit and the
fact that there are supports at all in
this sense might not make that much
sense either because if this were really
a station fly by you to have some kind
of other support structure related to
the station building which I'm not
building so that's not something that I
can incorporate here so yeah I'm not too
sure what exactly to do with that and
just put some quick posts in there for
now to make it look a bit better but the
rest is going to be up to must Bennet
and gikas in there to see what they can
do with it and I'm also extending the
steel supports of the lift Hill just
because there was a bit of a tight
situation down there and I thought you
know might as well connect these steel
supports and make the entire lift Hill
structure based on steel supports
but yeah also another problem that I I'm
not gonna have to deal with anymore but
that I'm definitely leaving behind is
the idea of what to do with the queue
I put the queue or really the the
entrance building to the station at the
bank of the station right now and it's
gonna go over and under some parts of
the wooden coaster track I have no idea
how that's gonna work yeah I think mask
bandits is trying to figure that out
right now but actually looking back at
my discord messages they've been sending
messages back and forth of what to do
with the queue I'm sorry about this one
guys but yeah I basically just left a
giant puzzle behind for whatever the
queue is gonna have to be like but the
rest of this area is quite well defined
I think there's the access road allowing
trucks and all kinds of services to
enter the park and there's an open plaza
right in front of the station with that
large stretched out airtime Hill going
over it which is all going to be pretty
much incorporated into the the park
layout designs which the others are
gonna come up with I also have to say
this coaster does feature some straight
sections which is a little bit unusual
for GCI coasters typically they just go
from curve to curve to curve without
straight airtime Hill for it without
straight airtime Hills for instance
which is you know the complete opposite
of traditional wooden coasters which are
mostly just straight airtime Hills so
the fact this coaster has a straight
airtime Hill just after the first drop
is a bit unusual but at the same time I
thought it worked really well with the
layouts of this coaster the idea is that
you have the main entrance to this
coaster that the big plaza that leads to
the area of this coaster it's it's gonna
have that straight airtime Hill going
straight over that Plaza with some kind
of no sign of the coaster or some kind
of logo right in front of it so I think
it should be a very interesting way to
enter this area and almost like a weenie
to drag people into the
you know going into the coaster so I
think that makes more sense from a park
layouts perspective than a coaster
layout perspective even if you're
probably gonna get some really good flow
to the air time on that airtime Hill I
actually barely checked the g-forces on
this coaster but from looks like I can
tell that it's gonna be some decently
strong airtime although not too strong
typically GCI coasters don't have real
strong like beyond - one vertical
g-force airtime so that's also something
to take note of I think you know what
else I haven't talked about that's
actually a really interesting facts
about GCI coasters and actually I don't
know if other wooden coasters do this or
which manufacturer specifically or which
coaster types specifically but GC I
always does this is they have slightly
banked brake runs and you rarely see
anybody actually do this but in real
life they're brake runs are typically
just a little bit banked so you're not
entirely straight on the brakes just
because they need the fins to break the
coaster to fall into the slots of the
brakes so I don't know I always thought
that was really interesting because I
always imagined that brake runs are
completely straight but not only do they
typically go down a little bit because
straight coaster track won't allow the
coaster to coast if you know any of the
drive tires for instance are down but
the track is also slightly banked so
you're kind of tilted on your side on
the brake runs as well and I don't know
I always thought that was very
interesting and it's hardly noticeable
maybe if you know about it and you pay
really close attention to it you can
notice it but if you don't know about it
you're probably never gonna be able to
pick up on it but I've seen some
coasters in planet coaster which
actually go out of their way to add a
banked brake run and it's just one of
those little nerdy elements where it's
like ah I see what you did there
most people would probably not recognize
it or or maybe maybe they will after
this video if this video blows up enough
but you know it probably won't but yeah
here you go just the little neat facts
to know about as I try to make my way
through the list of things that I want
to talk about to fill my time here and
i'm adding still supports to that whole
structure of that curve and you can
actually notice that most of my time of
building supports is that one curve i do
have to say some of the footage that i
cut out was from the other turns and the
the more close to the ground areas which
are all more or less the same and i
didn't take out any footage for the
large curve now this is actually kind of
interesting I'm adding some planks in
the middle of the rails and this is
something which will typically be used
whenever the coaster goes from one side
to the other in terms of banking so
whenever it goes from a curve to the
left and to the curves to the rights and
the catwalks moved from the left to the
right or the other way around
there'll be some blanks in the middle of
the rails so that you can walk from one
side of the rails to the other one so I
won't be placing too many of these it
really just depends where all of the
transitions between the curves are but
this is something that you'll notice if
you watch on right videos of wooden
coasters in real life or if you ever
ride a GCI yourself you'll notice that
whenever you're going from a bit curved
to the left to the right you'll see some
wooden planks on the middle of the track
which are just there for evacuation
purposes but it's one of those little
touches that are just something needs
and something simple to add for a little
bit of extra realism I do have to say
these blanks don't actually fit as well
as they could have
in hindsight it would have probably been
better to use the two meter
posts and then just use two of them in a
row but I think the planks are alright
enough so I let them stay after I
figured it would take a lot of time to
remove these and put something else in
for now I wanted to put my attention
towards something else we are in a zoo
of course so I wanted to have this
coaster to be a little bit quiet and not
wake up all of the animals just in
general it's it's pretty terrible if
you're running loud roller coasters in a
zoo so it's something that I noticed
gold striker does in California's Great
America which has residential areas
around the theme park is to put
styrofoam plates underneath the track to
block off the sound because well wooden
coaster tracks are quite open so if you
don't have these then all of the sounds
who's gonna travel straight through the
track especially on sections like this
where the track is very heavily banked
so they use these styrofoam boards to
prevent the sound from travelling there
as much as they can which is something
that I actually never really thought
about before but if you watch a POV of
God striker you'll see that you have you
know some white stuff underneath the
track and it's one of those things that
I always notice but never really gave a
second thought but when I was looking up
how to you know cancel noise on wooden
roller coasters because I was
specifically looking for ways to do that
for the zoo here I found out that this
is apparently how gold striker does it
so that's really interesting and the way
to add these into the track is also kind
of simple just the snap to whenever you
can which is in this case the rails and
sink them into the rails a little bit
sometimes you need to adjust them a bit
but for the most part it's just letting
them angle snap to the rails and
dragging them underneath the rails a
little bit and also yeah I'm just using
the odd shapes for this because they're
just about the right size in shape maybe
not the best texture but I think they
work well enough now this is also quite
interesting because the styrofoam alone
isn't going to block off the sound of
the wooden coaster enough I thought
so just like God Stryker I also want to
install some fences on the curves
although thankfully unlike God Stryker
we're not completely surrounded by areas
that we can't let any sound into so in
my case it's going to be just this curve
and just the upper part here where I
also want to add fences because there's
the crocodile area very close by I asked
masked if they were crocodiles or
alligators but apparently you didn't
know either so I'm just gonna assume
that like crocodiles I have to be
completely honest this is one of these
things that I always forget the
difference and I always have to look it
up again and I'm not even gonna bother
this time because I'm just gonna forget
it anyway but yeah there are some
animals nearby on this side of the track
so that's why I'm installing fences
specifically on this side but not
anywhere else on the layout of the
coaster and the styrofoam pretty much
yeah the same goes for that one although
I also had some styrofoam on the lower
parts of the layout here just because I
want to make sure that the coaster is
it's quiet as possible on this side and
I had to make all of these fences custom
with blanks as well because obviously
the in-game fences while they do look
really nice they don't quite follow the
shape of their rails the same way so I
have to do it this way but I think it
works out alright and then finally there
are some wooden beams on top of the the
track here which I have no idea why
exactly they are like this because they
are shaped as though it were a tunnel
but there's really only offenses on one
side of it but God Stryker does this as
well so I figured her might as well I'm
not entirely sure what the purpose is
but it looks alright so I just added
that in there and here's another smaller
detail which is also interesting and
quite important to add everywhere which
is iron girders whenever the track is
crossing itself
so obviously wood isn't the strongest of
materials even though it is pretty
strong but usually whenever the the
wooden supports need to cover a bigger
distance like when
one part of the track is diving
underneath another one metal girders are
used to hold up the rest of the track so
I'm just installing these and all of the
the crossroads different coaster tracks
so that should more or less work to hold
up everything and there's not too much
that I need to do here in terms of
custom supporting I'm just trying to
make these things fit as much as
possible the in-game supports now this
point I also realized that past bandits
and geek ISM doesn't want to build on
this side of the road at all so I pretty
much had to finish my supports here and
remove the path that I had for the
longest time on this side because I was
thinking of some kind of pedestrian
bridge going over the access road and
integrating in some kind of large themed
area here but apparently we don't really
need to go in that direction so I needed
to finish some of the supports on the
side here and that all be it's the rest
of the theming and how the access road
is gonna be hidden if at all isn't up to
me to decide I'll just leave that up to
the other guys but yeah I'm just
finishing up as much as I can the
different supports here so that whatever
the case and whenever they still need to
theme and answer this ride which is
still very unfinished they don't have to
come back and do this whole supporting
job because God knows that it's quite a
tough job to do as far as doing stuff
and planet coaster goes you know it's
it's still a game in the end but if
there were any dirty jobs within this
little microcosm of the gameplay you'd
think I I think making wooden coaster
supports is definitely one of the
top-ranked dirty jobs here it's it's
pretty hard work but at the same time I
was really glad to just put up some
podcasts and some music and try and get
my mind on other things and just
brainlessly
put some wooden posts in this game so in
in a sense it's also kind of therapeutic
because it's just such a brainless
activity that you can just relax and do
something else also in the meantime
but yeah with that I have to say we've
actually reached the end of this
time-lapse so Wow I'm kind of impressed
that I managed to get it this far so I
hope you guys enjoyed this little
two-part miniseries about making a
winnin coaster in planet coaster if you
want to see the rest of the Azzurri
garden series I highly recommend it it's
a really cool park with some really
beautiful scenery and also if you're
curious to see what else will become of
this coaster which I know I am because I
have no idea
you should definitely follow the rest of
the series as well just like in the last
episode I'll link it down in the
description for now enjoy the cinematic
videos that I'll be including here and
the POV at last and I hope to see you
guys next time
in another planet coaster video where
I'm hopefully not placing wooden posts
for the whole episode bye guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]